thank you for your interest in nucleus
medical media we hope you enjoy this
video explaining our production process
our animation team produces a creative
brief for you based on your initial
proposal this brief includes the goals
of your project the intended audience
style and what to expect from the final
deliverable our writers work with you to
create a script of the action in your
video this script includes narration if
you want it before the script is
finalized you will have the opportunity
to review the script for accuracy and
visual flow next we use the script to
build models for your animation and
create a storyboard at this step will
point out key frames to describe our
concept of what's happening in the
animation and what the narrator is
saying at each point you will get
another chance to review it to make sure
we're on the right track we will advise
you to check for items such as accuracy
object placement general textures and
camera angles from there we create
what's called an animatic this is a
rough draft of the animation that we
provide to clients as one more review
step before the final product watch your
animatic for details such as how objects
move timing transitions camera motion
and narration quality note the colors
will not be as vibrant as the final
animation when you're happy with your
animatic we'll move on to the final
animation our animators enhance your
animation with elaborate textures
lighting and special effects creating an
animation that exceeds your expectations
when your animation is finished you'll
take a final look to make sure it's
everything you wanted and more our
post-production team adds your logos and
delivers the animation in the file
formats you need you have complete
control of this fun creative process if
you're interested in working with
nucleus please contact us using our toll
free number or visit our website